Hey there, everybody. Ira Glass here. So last week our program, This American Life, won a Pulitzer Prize. It was the very first Pulitzer ever awarded to a radio show or podcast or audio journalism of any kind. Among broadcasters, this was always kind of a sore point. I have to say that the highest award in journalism, the Pulitzer, was off limits to us. They would not consider us at all for any awards. In fact, a whole other award, the Peabody Award, was started in 1940 as a prize for broadcasters, and one of the reasons that it was was that broadcasters wanted their own version of the Pulitzer.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。上周，我们的节目《美国生活》获得了普利策奖。这是史上第一个授予广播节目、播客或任何形式音频新闻的普利策奖。在广播从业者中，这一直是个痛点。不得不说，新闻界的最高奖项普利策奖曾对我们是禁区。他们根本不会考虑让我们参与任何奖项评选。事实上，皮博迪奖是1940年作为广播从业者的奖项而设立的，原因之一就是广播从业者想要一个属于他们自己的“普利策奖”版本。
So needless to say, everybody here was very excited to get the award, very excited to be the very first broadcasters to do this. And today we're going to replay the episode that won-- it first ran this past November-- about things happening at the Mexican border. And what we're going to do is we're going to play the original episode. I'm going to jump in here and there with updates. But mostly you're going to hear what we originally broadcast.
不用说，这里的所有人都对获得该奖项感到非常兴奋，也非常激动能成为首个获此殊荣的广播人。今天我们要重播那期获奖剧集——它最初是在去年11月播出的——关于美墨边境发生的事情。我们将播放最初的剧集，我会不时插播一些最新情况。但主要还是你们最初听到的那个广播版本。
Just FYI, the stuff that we describe happening at the border is pretty much all still happening today, even with COVID-19. And what else do I want to say? The little boy that we start the show with, we have a big update on him at the end of the show. He is not at the border anymore, and we talked to him about it this week. Anyway, I'm saying too much. Here's the show.
顺便提一下，我们描述的边境所发生的事情，即使在新冠疫情期间，也基本都在继续。还有什么我想说的吗？节目开头提到的那个小男孩，我们在节目结尾会有关于他的重要后续报道。他已经不在边境了，我们这周和他聊了聊。总之，我说得太多了，节目开始吧。
Darwin's nine. And he's a kid who-- I don't know-- people just give him stuff. When he met my co-worker, Aviva, he was playing with a soccer ball somebody gave him, eating a taco somebody else gave him. Darwin's mom was explaining all this.
达尔文九岁。他是个——怎么说呢——人们总是主动给他东西。当他见到我的同事阿维娃时，他正在玩别人给他的足球，吃着别人给他的塔可饼。达尔文的妈妈解释了这一切。
Comemos más porque nos traigan.
我们吃得越多，是因为人们给我们送来食物。
Can you just describe what just happened?
你能描述一下刚刚发生了什么吗？
No tengo ni idea.
我不知道。
I have no idea, she says.
她说她不知道。
A man, as you were talking about people just giving him things, walked by and gave you-- how much did he give you? Diez?
就在你谈论人们主动给他东西时，一个男人走过来，给了你——他给了你多少钱？十个？
Diez.
十个。
Wow.
哇。
Diez pesos.
十比索。
10 pesos.
10比索。
Y por que te dio eso?
他为什么要给你那个？
Why'd he give you that? Aviva asks him. Darwin gives a little shrug like, eh, what can I say?
阿维娃问他为什么要给他那个。达尔文耸了耸肩，好像在说，呃，我能说什么呢？
Porque pensaba que yo estaba pidiendo una moneda.
因为他以为我在乞讨硬币。
Because he thought I was asking for a coin. His mom says, he was just sitting there eating.
因为他以为我在要硬币。他妈妈说，他当时只是坐在那儿吃东西。
You're, like, king of the camp.
你简直是营地的国王。
Que si, soy el rey del campamento!
没错，我是营地的国王！
Yes, I am the king of the camp, he says. As Aviva sits there with Darwin's mom, Elizabeth, he runs off for 15, 20 minutes at a time, and then returns with cash.
他说，没错，我是营地的国王。当阿维娃和达尔文的妈妈伊丽莎白坐在一起时，他一次次跑开15、20分钟，然后带着现金回来。
Ay Dios mio, santo Dios. Cinco dolares.
天哪，上帝啊。五美元。
Cinco! Dolar!
五美元！
$5.00. She hugs him.
5美元。她拥抱了他。
Ay, tan lindo. Muchachito.
哎，真可爱。小家伙。
Darwin runs to their tent to pull out all the money he's saved and show Aviva-- $279, a huge wad of cash, which for context, they're living in a makeshift tent camp in Matamoros, Mexico, right over the border from Brownsville, Texas. And, I mean, immediately on the other side, nestled against the US and the Rio Grande and the customs office. You can see the big red arches of the border station it's so close.
达尔文跑向他们的帐篷，拿出他攒下的所有钱给阿维娃看——279美元，一大叠现金。说明一下，他们住在这个墨西哥马塔莫罗斯的临时帐篷营地，就在得克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的边境对面。我的意思是，就在另一边，紧邻美国、格兰德河和海关办公室。你能看到边境站的大红色拱门，离得非常近。
Over 2,500 people living here, hoping to get asylum in the US. Darwin and his mom came here from Honduras. $279 here is huge. Most people, even the migrants who came with a little money saved, have been here so long they spent it all. Our family sends us money, his mom says. Lots of families do that. But he brings in so much more than they send.
这里住着超过2500人，希望能在美国获得庇护。达尔文和他的妈妈是从洪都拉斯来的。279美元在这里是一大笔钱。大多数人，即使是带了一点积蓄来的移民，也因为住得太久而花光了所有钱。他妈妈说，我们的家人给我们寄钱。很多家庭都这样做。但他赚的远比他们寄来的多。
Es inteligentísimo.
他非常聪明。
Aviva then follows Darwin as he walks from the tents to the long line of cars that's waiting at the border to cross into the United States. He's a happy-looking kid with neatly cut hair and a big smile, really cute. Darwin gives a fist bump to the fruit stand guy, claps the man selling corn on the back to say hello, nods to the half-dozen other vendors working the line. Remember, he's nine.
阿维娃随后跟着达尔文从帐篷走到等待过境进入美国的汽车长队中。他是个看起来很开心的孩子，头发整齐，笑容满面，真的很可爱。达尔文和水果摊的老板碰拳，拍拍卖玉米的男人的背打招呼，向那排工作的其他六个小贩点头。记住，他才九岁。
When we asked one woman in the camp about him, she was like, oh, El Terremoto-- The Earthquake. He holds a finger in the air asking for one coin. He says that's his move-- ask for a coin, and then hopefully they'll give you more than a coin. And, in fact, a car with three women waves him over, and the woman in the passenger seat rolls down her window and hands him a dollar.
当我们问营地里的一位女性关于他的情况时，她说，哦，他是“地震”。他举起一个手指要一个硬币。他说那是他的招牌动作——要一个硬币，然后希望能得到比硬币更多的东西。事实上，一辆载着三个女人的车向他招手，副驾驶座上的女人摇下车窗递给他一美元。
Gracias. Que los bendiga!
谢谢。祝你们好运！
Thanks. Bless you. Are you Cuban? He asks her.
谢谢。祝你们好运！你是古巴人吗？他问她。
Es Cubana?
你是古巴人吗？
Puerto Rico.
波多黎各人。
Ya reconoci.
我知道了。
He says, I knew it-- from your accent. And she's like, right, you thought I was from Cuba. And they laugh. The woman asks his name, and he tells her.
他说，我知道——从你的口音。她回答，没错，你以为我是古巴人。他们笑了。那个女人问他的名字，他告诉了她。
Darwin?
达尔文？
She says she likes his hair. I like your hair, he says. He reaches out to stroke her hair. It's straight and blond. I like your hair because it's pretty, he says. She laughs and claps her hands. Look at what a flirt he ended up being.
她说她喜欢他的头发。他说，我喜欢你的头发。他伸手摸了摸她的头发。是直的金发。他说，我喜欢你的头发，因为它很漂亮。她笑了，拍了拍手。看他多会调情。
Mira coqueto salió este. Ay Dios mío, tu tienes novia?
看这孩子多会讨人喜欢。天哪，你有女朋友吗？
Oh, my god. You have a girlfriend?
天哪。你有女朋友吗？
Usted es. Usted es.
是你。是你。
Oh, my god!
天哪！
You! You!
是你！是你！
Bye, Darwin.
再见，达尔文。
Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。
Darwin runs to his mom, who's watching all this, and gives her the dollar. Both of them, and the thousands of other people camped here at the border-- to be clear, they're trying to follow the rules and enter the United States through a border station and formally apply for asylum. It used to be, you'd show up. If you passed a basic interview, which most people did, you'd wait in the US for your day in court.
达尔文跑向一直看着这一切的妈妈，把那一美元给了她。他们和成千上万在边境露营的人一样——明确地说，他们正试图遵守规则，通过边境站进入美国并正式申请庇护。过去，你只要出现，如果通过了基本的面谈（大多数人都能通过），你就可以在美国等待上庭日期。
But now it's all different. Under the Trump administration's Remain in Mexico policy, you get turned back to wait in Mexico. This policy is still pretty new. It really kicked in full force this summer, but it's a profound change with massive consequences.
但现在一切都变了。在特朗普政府的“留在墨西哥”政策下，你会被遣返回墨西哥等待。这项政策还很新。它在今年夏天全面施行，但这是一个后果严重的深远改变。
One of them, the size of this camp, which didn't exist before President Trump. And all across Mexico, in cities just on the other side of the border, there are now tens of thousands of people-- according to the Department of Homeland Security-- stranded under this policy, in shelters, on the streets, and in encampments like this one, sent by our government without much of a plan for where or how they'd live once they got to Mexico.
后果之一就是这个营地的规模，在特朗普总统上任前它并不存在。在墨西哥全国各地，就在边境另一侧的城市里，现在有成千上万的人——根据国土安全部的说法——因这项政策而滞留，住在收容所、街头和像这样的营地里。我们的政府将他们送往墨西哥，却没有为他们到了那里后的生活制定什么计划。
This camp, for instance, is totally improvised-- long rows of scruffy blue and white and gray tents, over 700 of them, donated by do-gooder groups and churches in America. Coleman tents meant for weekend camping, not designed for rain and direct sun and cold for months at a time. There's no regular water supply here. Volunteer groups from over the border in Brownsville haul in over 3,000 bottles of water each day. And these are just the little 16-ounce bottles like you would buy with you lunch at a fast food place.
以这个营地为例，它完全是临时的——长长一排破旧的蓝色、白色和灰色帐篷，超过700个，由美国的善心团体和教堂捐赠。那是供周末露营用的科尔曼帐篷，不是为抵御数月的雨水、阳光和寒冷而设计的。这里没有稳定的供水。从布朗斯维尔过来的志愿者团体每天运送3000多瓶水。这些只是你在快餐店买午餐时那种16盎司的小瓶水。
There's no proper sanitation-- just five toilets for over 2,500 people, yellow Porta Potties, which get precisely as gross as you would imagine. One of the fathers here, Elwin David Baquis, told me that when his 8-year-old daughter needs the bathroom--
这里没有像样的卫生设施——2500多人只有五个黄色移动厕所，它们和你想象的一样恶心。这里的一位父亲埃尔温·大卫·巴基斯告诉我，当他8岁的女儿需要上厕所时——
No, pues si cuando tengo dinero le busco otro baño.
不，如果有钱的话，我会给她找别的厕所。
Well, you know, if I have some money, then I'll look and see if I can find her another bathroom to use. But if there isn't any, then I'll take her out into the woods, into the mountain, so that she can use the bathroom, do her business, and then we'll go down to the river to wash up.
嗯，你知道，如果我有钱，我会看看能不能给她找个别的厕所。但如果没有，我就带她到树林里、山上去，让她上厕所，解决问题，然后我们再去河边洗洗。
Para tantas personas. No tienen ni cinco horas cuando ya están repletos.
人太多了。不到五个小时就满了。
And honestly, with the amount of people using them, in five hours, they'll be totally full. And people still keep on going to use them, especially women, because as you can imagine, there's a bunch of men out there in the woods that are using the bathroom, and they don't want to be surrounded by that.
老实说，按照使用的人数，五个小时内它们就完全满了。人们还是得去用，尤其是女性，因为你可以想象，外面树林里有很多男人在排泄，她们不想被那些东西包围。
There's a nurse at the camp named Helen Perry who runs a very small relief group with a very grand sounding name-- Global Response Management. With some volunteers, she started a medical tent camp, modeled after the battalion aid stations that she learned to set up back when she was in the Army. Anyway, I mentioned all this to Helen-- that this father and daughter were going up in the woods-- and she was like, oh yeah, knew that.
营地里有一位护士叫海伦·佩里，她经营着一个名字听起来很宏大的小型救援组织——全球应对管理。她带了一些志愿者，建立了一个医疗帐篷营地，仿照她参军时学会建立的营级援助站。总之，我向海伦提到了这一切——那对父女要去树林里上厕所——她说，哦是的，我知道。
Yeah. And then when it rains, all that rainwater washes down there. Or it washes into the hard spaces in the camp, and they get, you know, infectious diarrhea. So--
是的。然后下雨时，所有的雨水都会冲到那里。或者冲进营地的硬地空间，他们就会感染传染性腹泻。所以——
Are you seeing a lot of infectious diarrhea?
你看到很多传染性腹泻病例吗？
Yes. Most everyone here has some form of GI something or other-- you know, different types of tapeworms and ringworms. And the problem is that you treat it, and then they come right back out and they get it again.
是的。这里几乎每个人都有某种肠胃问题——你知道，各种绦虫和蛲虫。问题是，你治疗了它们，然后他们又回到外面，再次被感染。
I actually met Elwin because he was Helen's first patient of the day. He and his daughter both had pinkeye from bathing in the Rio Grande, which is not clean. Helen's trying to organize a fix for that.
我之所以认识埃尔温，是因为他是海伦当天的第一位病人。他和女儿因为在格兰德河里洗澡都得了红眼病，那河水并不干净。海伦正在努力组织解决这个问题。
So this is actually one of the areas that we're talking about bringing in a water purification system. So the Rio Grande is, like, right down there. Hola.
所以这实际上是我们正在谈论引入水净化系统的区域之一。所以格兰德河就在下面。你好。
Hola.
你好。
And so what we want to do is put in a water purification system right over here, run a hose out into the water, it'll suck up the water, purify it, and they'll have their own water source.
所以我们想在这里安装一个水净化系统，把软管伸进水里，它会吸入水，进行净化，这样他们就有自己的水源了。
And you're the one organizing this?
你是负责组织这件事的人吗？
Yeah. So--
是的。所以——
Not a government.
不是政府。
No.
不是。
Not the UN?
不是联合国？
Nope.
不是。
Just you, a person.
只是你，一个普通人。
I've never-- people are like, have you done water? And I'm like, no, but, like, I'll Google it.
我从未——人们问我，你做过净水吗？我说，没有，但我会去谷歌查一下。
I have to say, this is the thing that hit me hardest in Matamoros. You have thousands of people stuck there, right on our border. Two big governments, the United States and Mexico, one of them, of course, a lot richer than the other. And nobody's looking after these people with food and water and shelter except a bunch volunteers who raised their hands and said, we cannot ignore this.
不得不说，这是我在马塔莫罗斯感触最深的一件事。成千上万的人被困在那里，就在我们的边界。两个大国，美国和墨西哥，其中一个当然比另一个富裕得多。除了那些举手说“我们不能无视这一点”的志愿者之外，没有人关心这些人的饮食、饮水和住所。
Buenas tardes. Hoy día tenemos voluntarios que vienen de Indiana.
下午好。今天我们有来自印第安纳州的志愿者。
Good afternoon. Today we have volunteers from Indiana.
Y de Indianapolis.
还有来自印第安纳波利斯的。
From Indianapolis.
来自印第安纳波利斯。
Muy lejos!
好远！
Really far.
太远了。
A cocinar para ustedes.
来为你们做饭。
To cook for you.
Porque todos somos hermanos, verdad.
因为我们都是兄弟，对吧。
Because we're all brothers, right?
So les vamos a decir gracias. Un aplauso para nuestros voluntarios.
所以我们要说谢谢。让我们为我们的志愿者鼓掌。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
So let's say thanks with a round of applause. Eight very nice ladies from Indiana in fluorescent green t-shirts start serving food out of aluminum foil trays, food for 1,000 people. It cost $1,900, which they raised back home in $20 donations. They also paid for their own flights and everything.
所以让我们用掌声表示感谢。八位来自印第安纳州、身穿荧光绿T恤的善良女士开始从铝箔托盘中分发食物，这是供1000人吃的食物。花费了1900美元，这是她们在家乡通过每笔20美元的捐款筹集到的。她们还自己承担了机票和所有费用。
An impressively competent group that calls itself Team Brownsville, started by a bunch of teachers, all volunteer, has organized this so a different bunch of people shows up five nights a week with food. They also pay for a Matamoros restaurant to deliver hundreds of breakfasts each day. The food today is fresh, but very north of the border and very plain-- slices of ham and cheese on white bread, tangerines, grapes, baby carrots. Everybody we ask about the food, though, is polite enough to say how great it is.
一个令人印象深刻、能力超强的团体，自称“布朗斯维尔团队”，由一群教师发起，全是志愿者。他们组织了这次活动，每周有五天会有不同的团体送来食物。他们还支付费用让一家马塔莫罗斯餐厅每天运送数百份早餐。今天的食物是新鲜的，但非常有美国北方特色，非常简单——白面包夹火腿和奶酪、柑橘、葡萄、胡萝卜。不过，我们问到的每个人对食物都很有礼貌，说它很棒。
Pues rica.
很美味。
Si?
是吗？
Si. Todos los dias
是。每天都是。
It's tasty, this guy tells Aviva.
这个男人告诉阿维娃，这很美味。
La comida es rica? Bien rica. Si.
食物好吃吗？非常好吃。是的。
It's tasty, right? He says to the woman next to him. Oh, sure, very tasty, she says. Soon as Aviva walks away, the interpreter who was with us for the day, Gabby Muñoz, overhears what happens next.
她说食物很好吃，对吧？她对旁边的女人说。哦，当然，非常好吃，她说。当阿维娃走开后，我们当天的翻译加比·穆尼奥斯无意中听到了接下来的谈话。
Oh, yeah. Then afterwards, her friend, or the guy-- the person's friend, was like, what did she ask you? And he's like, well, she asked me how good the food was. And I said it was good, but what the fuck else was I supposed to say?
哦，是的。后来，她的朋友，或者那个人的朋友问她，她问了你什么？他说，嗯，她问我食物怎么样。我说很好，但除此之外我还能说什么他妈的话呢？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Generally they try to get the volunteers out of the camp by nightfall, because Matamoros isn't safe. The cartels are here. The city has one of the highest kidnapping rates in Mexico according to the US State Department. Its web page about Matamoros says, murder, carjacking, and sexual assault are common. Gang gun battles are widespread. Anybody here is at high risk.
他们通常尽量在天黑前让志愿者离开营地，因为马塔莫罗斯并不安全。贩毒集团就在这里。根据美国国务院的数据，该市是墨西哥绑架率最高的城市之一。关于马塔莫罗斯的网页称，谋杀、抢车和性侵犯很常见。帮派枪战广泛存在。这里的任何人风险都很高。
Not far from where they serve the food, like, just 20 feet or so from the actual border station, a woman named Jenny and her husband and her daughter set up their tent. I asked her if she chose that spot because it seemed like the safest, closest into the border like that.
在他们分发食物的地方不远处，就在离实际边境站大约20英尺的地方，一个叫珍妮的女人和她的丈夫女儿搭起了帐篷。我问她是否因为觉得这里最安全、离边境最近才选了这个地方。
Si, es más seguro...
是的，这更安全……
She said yes and explained that she and her husband and daughter had been kidnapped in the last city they were in.
她说是的，并解释说她和丈夫女儿在他们所在的上一个城市被绑架了。
Fue en Reynosa. Quince días estuvimos secuestrados.
是在雷诺萨。我们被绑架了15天。
So it was in Reynosa, and we were kidnapped for 15 days.
所以是在雷诺萨，我们被绑架了15天。
She starts to tell the story of her family and the cartel and the house they were held in. But as she does, a man quietly approaches and just kind of hovers nearby, listening. And she says, atrás, atrás, atrás-- look behind you-- and covers her face.
她开始讲述她家庭和贩毒集团以及他们被囚禁的房子的故事。但就在这时，一个男人悄悄走过来，在附近徘徊、偷听。她说，在后面，在后面，在后面——看看你后面——然后捂住脸。
Atrás atrás atrás. Están viendo. Atrás. No hay que hablar de eso. Están atrás.
在后面，在后面。他们在看。在后面。不要谈论那个。他们在后面。
You can't talk about this. He's behind.
你不能谈论这个。他在后面。
Peligroso.
危险。
We switch the subject. He goes away. A journalist who's in this camp a lot confirmed that he was a cartel guy. How much violence there is against people in the camp is not clear. The nurse, Helen Perry, has heard about people being kidnapped from the camp, but that's hard to confirm. And she told me this story.
我们转换了话题。他离开了。一位经常在营地活动的记者证实他是贩毒集团的人。营地里针对人们的暴力程度尚不清楚。护士海伦·佩里听说过有人从营地被绑架，但这很难证实。她告诉了我这个故事。
When I first showed up in the camp, a woman came up to me and asked me if we would be bringing in condoms, because when she got sexually assaulted again, she wanted to be able to ask her attacker to wear a condom so she wouldn't get pregnant.
我刚到营地时，一个女人走过来问我，我们是否会带避孕套过来，因为当她再次被性侵时，她想让攻击者戴上避孕套，这样她就不会怀孕。
In her relief work, Helen's been to lots of places where migrants and refugees are stranded like this. But the security issues here, the lack of predictable food and water and sanitation, five toilets where there should be 125, no proper tents for people--
在救援工作中，海伦去过许多像这样移民和难民滞留的地方。但这里的安全问题，食物、饮水和卫生的不可预知性，125人应有的厕所只有五个，没有适合人们的帐篷——
When I first saw it, I was literally just dumbfounded. Because I've seen refugee situations like this. I've been to Bangladesh. I've seen Cox's Bazar. I've been to Iraq. I've seen the IDP camps. I've seen the refugee camps from Syria. I'd say this was the worst. Yeah, I would definitely say that this is the worst, if at a bare minimum for a lack of humanitarian accountability for what's happening to these people.
我第一次看到它时，真的是惊呆了。因为我见过这样的难民情况。我去过孟加拉国，见过考克斯巴扎尔。我去过伊拉克，见过境内流离失所者营地，见过叙利亚难民营。我会说这是最糟糕的。是的，我绝对会说这是最糟糕的，如果仅从对这些人发生的事情缺乏人道主义问责来看的话。
You mean that nobody's keeping a count of who's here and who isn't, who goes in and who goes out.
你的意思是，没有人统计谁在这里，谁不在，谁进，谁出。
Who goes in, who goes out, who goes missing.
谁进，谁出，谁失踪了。
At a proper refugee camp, she says, like a United Nations camp, they'd have that-- a big tall fence, somebody keeping track of who comes in and out. When we asked Mexican officials about conditions in this camp, they said they aren't helping the 2,500 people here because they don't want a permanent tent city in the spot. They want people to move to government shelters. And the United Nations said they won't step in unless the Mexican government invites them to step in.
她说，在一个像样的难民营，比如联合国的营地，他们会有这些——一道高高的围栏，有人记录谁进出。当我们问墨西哥官员营地的条件时，他们说他们没有帮助这里的2500人，因为他们不想在这个地方建立永久的帐篷城。他们希望人们搬到政府收容所。而联合国表示，除非墨西哥政府邀请，否则他们不会介入。
The United States, whose policies landed people here in the first place, has also donated $5 million to house them in Mexico. The money doesn't go to tent camps like this one but to the official Mexican government shelters. It's enough money to shelter 8,000 people.
美国，其政策导致人们滞留在这里，也捐赠了500万美元在墨西哥收容他们。这笔钱并没有用于像这样的帐篷营地，而是给了墨西哥官方政府收容所。这足以收容8000人。
But we sent way more people than that back across the border, over 57,000, under the Remain in Mexico policy, plus another 21,000 who immigration officials haven't even begun to process. We've told them, the system's backed up. You should sit on a waiting list, stay in Mexico, and we'll get to your cases in a few months. And these are mostly people who in the past, before President Trump, would have been allowed into the United States to wait for their asylum court dates here.
但我们在“留在墨西哥”政策下送回边境的人远不止这个数字，超过5.7万人，再加上另外2.1万名移民官员甚至还没开始处理的人。我们告诉他们，系统积压了。你们应该在等候名单上待着，留在墨西哥，几个月后我们会处理你们的案件。这些人大多数在特朗普总统之前，本来是被允许进入美国等待他们的庇护庭审日期的。
It's so many people we're pushing back across the border, resulting in refugee camps that we don't call refugee camps right on our country's doorstep. Today we try to understand what this new policy means for the people we send across the border. We also hear from US officials who sent them there who are not feeling so great about it themselves. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们推回到边境的人太多了，导致我们在国境线上出现了我们不称之为难民营的难民营。今天我们试着去理解这项新政策对我们送往边境的人意味着什么。我们还会听到那些把他们送走、自己对此也感到不太好受的美国官员的声音。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Goodbye, Stranger." So like I said at the top of the program, today's show was first broadcast in November, and we are rerunning it today because it just won the Pulitzer Prize. This is one of the spots where I'm jumping into the original broadcast to say, the president's policies at the border have only intensified since we first broadcast this show. Since COVID-19 in March, the administration shut down the border to all asylum seekers. Asylum hearings aren't going to resume until late June, though it seems possible that even that date is going to get pushed back.
第一幕，“再见，陌生人。”正如我在节目开头所说，今天的节目最初在11月播出，我们今天重播是因为它刚刚获得了普利策奖。这是我插播原始广播的地方，总统在边境的政策自我们首次播出该节目以来只会更加强化。自3月新冠疫情以来，政府关闭了所有寻求庇护者的边境。庇护听证会直到6月下旬才会恢复，尽管看起来即使那个日期也可能被推迟。
When we first broadcast this program, one of the things that we were especially interested in was the US officials on the front lines whose job under Remain in Mexico is to send people back. Lots of them were resigning, saying, no, that's actually not my job. Los Angeles Times reporter, Molly O'Toole, talked to a bunch of them. And here is the version of the story that we ran in the fall.
当我们首次播出这个节目时，我们特别感兴趣的事情之一就是那些在“留在墨西哥”政策下负责送人回去的一线美国官员。他们中许多人辞职了，说，不，那其实不是我的工作。《洛杉矶时报》记者莫莉·奥图尔采访了他们中的一些人。这是我们在秋季播出的故事版本。
Before the Remain in Mexico policy began and upended the asylum system and completely changed what it is to be an asylum officer, here's how the job used to work. When a Central American showed up at the US-Mexico border and said, "Let me in, I'm afraid of going back to my country," that's where the asylum officer came in.
在“留在墨西哥”政策开始并颠覆庇护制度、彻底改变什么是庇护官员之前，这项工作原本是这样运作的。当一个中美洲人出现在美墨边境说，“让我进去，我怕回到我的国家，”庇护官员就会介入。
The officer did something called a credible fear screening to check if the person was likely to face harm or death if the US sent them back home. If there's even a chance that they would, the asylum officer would let them into the United States to wait for a court date, where an immigration judge would make the final call. Doug Stephens says people don't understand how hard the job is. At the time all this started, he was an asylum officer in San Francisco.
官员会进行所谓的“可信恐惧甄别”，以检查如果美国把这个人送回去，他们是否可能面临伤害或死亡。如果有一点这种可能，庇护官员就会让他们进入美国等待法庭日期，由移民法官做出最终决定。道格·斯蒂芬斯说，人们不明白这份工作有多难。在这一切开始时，他是旧金山的庇护官员。
And so I'd have people come into my office. And my job essentially is, tell me the worst things that have happened to you. You have an hour. Go. And then I'll decide if you're telling me the truth, and I'll decide if you get to stay.
所以我会让人进我的办公室。我的工作本质上是，告诉我发生在你身上最糟糕的事情。你有一个小时。开始。然后我会决定你是否在说实话，并决定你是否能留下来。
You are expected to be-- or, really, to do the job well, need to be-- an expert in the political, cultural, social, and economic situations in innumerable countries around the world. And you're expected to be a human lie detector, all at once.
你被期望成为——或者说，为了做好这项工作，需要成为——世界上无数国家政治、文化、社会和经济状况的专家。同时，你还得是一个人体测谎仪。
President Trump talks about asylum itself as if it's fraud. He says it's a hoax, a big fat con job, that people come in with fake asylum claims, that asylum officers just let everyone through, and then asylum seekers never show up for their day in court, that it's a border-wide, 2,000-mile loophole. And it's true that most people do pass that first step with an asylum officer and enter the United States.
特朗普总统谈论庇护本身就好像它是欺诈。他说这是一个骗局，一个彻头彻尾的把戏，人们拿着虚假的庇护申请进来，庇护官员让每个人都通过，然后寻求庇护者从不到庭应诉，说这是一个跨越2000英里的边界漏洞。确实，大多数人确实通过了庇护官员的第一步并进入了美国。
But there's a good reason for that. It's built into US asylum law-- a commonsense humanitarian idea. We don't want to send people back to situations where they'd get tortured or killed. The legal term is non-refoulment. And so US law set the bar low. If there's basically any chance an asylum seeker could get killed or harmed, the officer is supposed to let them into the US and doesn't need a lot of proof or evidence at that point.
但这是有正当理由的。它根植于美国庇护法——一个常识性的人道主义理念。我们不想把人送回他们会被折磨或杀害的地方。法律术语是“不推回原则”。因此，美国法律降低了门槛。如果寻求庇护者基本上有任何可能被杀害或伤害，官员就应该让他们进入美国，不需要在那个阶段提供大量证据。
Later, when they get before an immigration judge-- and by the way, the majority do show up-- there they need proof. And most of them get rejected. Even before President Trump took office, less than 15% per year got asylum, and that's because most people don't meet the specific criteria in the law, or don't have enough evidence. Or it doesn't check out. All the asylum officers I've ever spoken with see it as their job to weed out the fakers, the people who don't really need protection, the ones who are just trying to game the system.
后来，当他们出现在移民法官面前时——顺便说一下，大多数人确实出现了——他们才需要证据。大多数人被拒绝。即使在特朗普总统就任之前，每年获得庇护的比例不到15%，那是因为大多数人不符合法律规定的具体标准，或者没有足够的证据。或者情况不属实。所有我采访过的庇护官员都把他们的工作视为剔除伪造者，那些并不真正需要保护、只是试图利用系统的人。
Oh, my god. Like, here's where I'm going to be real with you.
天哪。在这里我要对你坦诚。
This is an asylum officer we're calling Ursula. This isn't her voice. She's afraid of getting fired, so we had an actor copy what she said as closely as possible.
这是一位我们称为“厄休拉”的庇护官员。这不是她的声音。她害怕被解雇，所以我们让一位演员尽可能准确地复制了她所说的话。
The fraud is, like, happening on a scale that's ri-- that's huge. We're talking, like, hundreds of people a month.
欺诈行为正在以一种巨大的规模发生。我们说的是，每个月有数百人。
I interviewed three asylum officers for this story. And all three said the groups that have been the primary target of President Trump's immigration policies, they actually aren't the main ones committing fraud.
我为这个故事采访了三名庇护官员。所有三个人都说，那些成为特朗普总统移民政策主要目标的人，实际上并不是主要的欺诈者。
It's not the Central Americans. It's not the Middle Eastern people. It is the Indian people and the Chinese people. They all have the same bullshit story about getting beaten with hockey sticks three times because they're part of a Sikh party, and the police told them they're going to jail them if they ever bad mouth the ruling party ever again. Bullshit.
不是中美洲人。不是中东人。而是印度人和中国人。他们都有同样荒谬的故事，说因为他们是锡克教派的成员而三次被曲棍球棒殴打，警察告诉他们，如果他们再敢说执政党的坏话，就会把他们关进监狱。胡扯。
They all just happened to do the same thing and suffer the same fate, even though there's absolutely no confirmation in any media that any of this persecution is happening, and studies done by our Department of State counterparts in the country are straight up like, this is not a real thing. The Chinese are running a similar scam with Christian claims.
他们都恰好做了同样的事情并遭受了同样的命运，尽管没有任何媒体证实这种迫害正在发生，我们国务院在该国的对应机构所做的研究也直接表明，这不是真实的事情。中国人也在用类似的基督教申诉进行诈骗。
In the fall of 2018, asylum officers started hearing about these big changes coming. The policy that was first called Remain in Mexico and then, later, Migrant Protection Protocols, MPP. But the asylum officers who were going to have to implement this thing, they didn't know any of the details of how they were supposed to do it.
2018年秋天，庇护官员开始听到这些即将到来的重大变化。这项政策最初被称为“留在墨西哥”，后来被称为“移民保护协议”（MPP）。但那些必须实施这项政策的庇护官员，却不知道他们该如何实施的任何细节。
It was all shrouded in so much secrecy.
一切都被笼罩在极度保密之中。
This is another asylum officer. We're calling her Anne. We used an actor here, too, to protect her identity. Over the next few weeks, Anne starts picking up around the office that some of her colleagues were being called in quietly and asked to go to the border in San Diego. And instead of the credible fear screenings they'd always done, they seemed to be doing something entirely different under MPP, a whole new kind of interview with different rules. She knew she was going to have to start doing them, too, so she pulled aside a coworker who'd already been sent to the border.
这是另一位庇护官员。我们也用了演员来保护她的身份。在接下来的几周里，安妮开始在办公室听到，她的一些同事被悄悄叫去，要求去圣迭戈边境。他们似乎不再做他们一直做的“可信恐惧甄别”，而是在MPP下做着完全不同的事情，一种带有不同规则的全新面试。她知道她也得开始做了，于是她拉住了一个已经被派往边境的同事。
I was asking her, hey, like, what's the training? Like, what is this? And she was like, I am not allowed to talk to you about it.
我问她，嘿，培训是什么样的？这是什么？她说，我不被允许和你谈论这件事。
Another asylum officer?
另一位庇护官员？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
Is this someone who you'd, like, consider a friend, or just sort of, like, professional colleague?
这是你认为的朋友，还是仅仅是职业同事？
Good colleague-- a good colleague, someone that we had mutual trust, for sure, and then was told-- was brought in by a supervisor for, like, a special brief about it before I was going to start doing these interviews, and was told, here's the skinny on it and don't tell anyone.
很好的同事——一个很好的同事，我们有相互信任的人，肯定是的。然后被主管叫去，在我要开始做这些面试之前，接受了一个关于它的特别简报，被告知，事情就是这样，不要告诉任何人。
Why?
为什么？
Because I think they knew that it was legally dubious and suspect, and they wanted to keep the leak to a minimum.
因为我想他们知道这在法律上是可疑的，他们想把泄密减少到最低限度。
The leak being a major policy rollout that was going to change asylum?
泄密是指一个将改变庇护政策的重大政策发布吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That's the leak?
那就是泄密？
That's the leak, yeah.
是的，那就是泄密。
Two months go by before they do a formal training session with the full asylum corps, and it's just a PowerPoint. Here's Ursula again.
两个月过去了，他们才用整个庇护部门做了正式培训，那只是一个PPT。厄休拉又来了。
Hands were going up and being like, wait, how is this legal? Or-- how are we going to be doing this, and how do we know how this works?
大家举手问，等等，这合法吗？或者——我们要怎么做，我们怎么知道它是如何运作的？
All three of the asylum officers I talked to said that the presentation left them with lots of questions, including the biggest one-- how is this legal? These officers knew better than almost anyone how dangerous Mexico is, and this policy seemed designed to send tons of people back to Mexico. It seemed to be in direct contradiction with US asylum law, which says that, at the very least, we can't send people back to a situation where they'd get harmed or killed. We can't violate the principle of non-refoulment.
我采访的所有三名庇护官员都说，演示让他们产生了很多疑问，包括最大的一个——这合法吗？这些官员比几乎任何人都清楚墨西哥有多危险，而这项政策似乎就是为了把大量的人送回墨西哥。它似乎与美国庇护法直接矛盾，美国庇护法规定，至少我们不能把人送回他们会被伤害或杀害的地方。我们不能违反“不推回原则”。
And the response was like, I'm just the messenger bringing this down from HQ, and this is the PowerPoint they gave us. I was like, well, if you don't even care about double checking that this is legal and you're just the messenger, as you say, you're a fucking asshole, you know?
他们的回应是，我只是从总部把这传达下来的信使，这就是他们给我们的PPT。我说，好吧，如果你甚至不关心核实这是否合法，而你只是如你所说的信使，那你真是个混蛋，你知道吗？
All three officers say they raised concerns and got roughly the same response-- just get out there and do your job. What they found out soon enough was just how radical a change the new MPP interviews were from the old credible fear screenings. For starters, not everyone would get an interview. Only the people who volunteered that they were scared to go back to Mexico would.
所有三名官员都说他们提出了担忧，得到的回答大致相同——只要出去做好你的工作就行了。他们很快发现，新的MPP面试与旧的“可信恐惧甄别”有着多么激进的改变。首先，并非每个人都能得到面试机会。只有那些自愿说他们害怕回到墨西哥的人才可以。
If they got an interview, under MPP, asylum seekers would have to prove that they'd be harmed in Mexico, not their home country. And not just any harm-- they can't just be threatened by gangs or the police. They have to be threatened by gangs, or, police or whoever because of some very specific reasons laid out in the US law-- because of their nationality, race, religion, politics, or being part of a particular social group, like LGBTQ.
如果他们得到了面试，在MPP下，寻求庇护者必须证明他们会在墨西哥受到伤害，而不是在他们的祖国。而且不仅仅是任何伤害——他们不能仅仅因为帮派或警察受到威胁。他们必须是因为美国法律规定的某些非常具体的原因——因为他们的国籍、种族、宗教、政治倾向，或属于特定的社会群体，比如LGBTQ——而受到帮派、警察或任何人的威胁。
And they'd have to show that the Mexican government, like a cop or an official, was unable or unwilling to protect them. And the asylum seeker couldn't just say all this happened, like they could under credible fear screenings. Now they'd need to prove it. It's like, as asylum seekers were traveling through Mexico, fleeing for their lives, they should have been gathering evidence of all the screwed up things happening to them there. Making a paper trail. And they should have had all of this evidence on them right then, right after crossing the border-- which, of course, is next to impossible, especially because they had no idea any of this was required.
而且他们必须证明墨西哥政府，比如警察或官员，无法或不愿保护他们。寻求庇护者不能只说这一切发生了，就像在“可信恐惧甄别”下那样。现在他们需要证明这一点。就像，当寻求庇护者穿越墨西哥、为生命奔波时，他们本应该收集所有发生在他们身上糟糕事情的证据。留下纸面记录。而且他们应该在那个时候、在越过边境后立刻就拥有所有这些证据——这当然是不可能的，尤其是因为他们根本不知道需要这些。
Doug saw all this happening and wanted nothing to do with it. So he tried to keep his head down to try and avoid having to do these interviews, hoping the courts would kill MPP. But they didn't. By June, MPP returns had skyrocketed, and it was all hands on deck for the asylum corps. Doug couldn't dodge it anymore.
道格看到了这一切发生，不想参与其中。于是他试图低调行事，避免参加这些面试，希望法院能废除MPP。但他们没有。到6月，MPP的遣返人数飙升，庇护部门全员出动。道格再也躲不掉了。
And I got the email.
我收到了那封电子邮件。
It said, you're doing MPP interviews today.
它说，你今天要做MPP面试。
So I had a father and son. The son, I think, was preteens, 11 or 12. They're fleeing Honduras because of violence and other problems. We didn't talk about that much because it doesn't matter for the purpose of MPP. I'm focused only on why they're afraid to go back to Mexico.
所以我接了一对父子。儿子我想是青春期前，11或12岁。他们因为暴力和其他问题逃离洪都拉斯。我们没怎么谈那个，因为对于MPP的目的来说并不重要。我只关注他们为什么害怕回到墨西哥。
Of course, the guy and his son don't understand why they're even talking about Mexico. They don't understand any of this at all. The interview continued.
当然，那个男人和他的儿子不明白为什么他们甚至在谈论墨西哥。他们根本不明白这一切。面试继续进行。
So he had tried to find a place to live there, had tried to get a work permit in Mexico, and was essentially denied. And as they're transiting, he's talking about, you know, encountering cartels and witnessing other migrants being murdered and tortured in front of his son-- and fleeing and barely getting away, you know, while death threats are being shouted at him. And, you know, talking about his son having nightmares for weeks because of this.
所以他曾尝试在那里找地方住，试图获得在墨西哥的工作许可，但基本上被拒绝了。在他过境时，他谈到遇到贩毒集团，目睹其他移民在他儿子面前被杀害和折磨——并逃离，几乎没能脱身，你知道，同时死亡威胁对他大喊。还有，谈到他儿子因为这个做了几周的噩梦。
And then they get stopped by the police. And the police take all of their money, their cell phones. And because I can't get them to say these magic words of like, yeah, they threatened me because I'm Honduran-- like, that's all they had to say. But they don't know that, right?
然后他们被警察拦住了。警察拿走了他们所有的钱、手机。因为我无法让他们说出那种魔力的话，比如，是的，他们因为我是洪都拉斯人而威胁我——那是他们唯一需要说的话。但他们不知道，对吧？
Because I'm Honduran. Those would be the magic words that would put them in a protected category. They were targeted because of their nationality. Though even if the father had said "because I'm Honduran," they probably still would have been sent back to Mexico, because odds are he didn't have any evidence proving that any of this happened. Doug, he did what the policy told him to do. He sent them back to Mexico.
因为我是洪都拉斯人。那些就是把他们置于受保护类别的魔力词。他们因为国籍而被针对。尽管即使父亲说了“因为我是洪都拉斯人”，他们可能仍然会被送回墨西哥，因为很可能他没有任何证明这一切发生的证据。道格做了政策告诉他做的事情。他把他们送回了墨西哥。
The old credible fear screenings usually took an hour or less. These MPP interviews can last four, five, six hours. When I asked these asylum officers to describe what these interviews are like-- for them, for the migrants in front of them. Ursula gave the most vivid picture. She told me about the very first MPP interview she did-- a family from El Salvador, two parents and two kids. She had a script she had to stick to. The family was exhausted, and traumatized, and totally unprepared.
旧的“可信恐惧甄别”通常需要一小时或更短。这些MPP面试可以持续四、五个、六个小时。当我让这些庇护官员描述这些面试是什么样时——对他们，对面前的移民。厄休拉给出了最生动的画面。她告诉我她做的第一次MPP面试——一个来自萨尔瓦多的家庭，两个父母和两个孩子。她有一个必须坚持的剧本。一家人精疲力竭，受到创伤，完全没有准备。
You're put into a cell. You're separated from your kids and your wife. You have no idea what's going on because you thought today you were going to be interviewed about El Salvador, and you were going to get to enter the United States. A couple hours later, they lead you into this freezing cold cell where they chain your hands to a table in handcuffs, and someone is sitting across from you who doesn't speak your language and starts talking to someone in the phone who starts translating to you that you're going to talk about Mexico.
你被关进牢房。你与孩子和妻子分开。你根本不知道发生了什么，因为你以为今天你会接受关于萨尔瓦多的面试，你将获准进入美国。几个小时后，他们把你带进这个寒冷刺骨的牢房，用手铐把你铐在桌子上，有人坐在你对面，不说你的语言，然后开始和电话里的人通话，那个人开始给你翻译，说你要谈论墨西哥。
You smell like shit because you've been living in a shelter without any running water for a month and a half, plus you've traveled all the way across Central America to get there, and you don't understand why someone is talking to you about Mexico. This interview goes on for an hour and a half, and the person keeps pausing it so they can talk to someone on the computer, which they say is their supervisor. And another guard leads your wife in that you haven't seen in the last 12 hours into the interview room. And you can, you know, brush her hand as she passes by. You're so happy to see her because you've been separated, and you have no idea what's going on.
你身上有屎味，因为你在没有自来水的收容所住了一个半月，加上你为了到达那里穿越了整个中美洲，而且你不明白为什么有人在和你谈论墨西哥。这次面试持续了一个半小时，那个人不停地暂停，以便他们可以在电脑上和某人交谈，他们说是他们的主管。另一个警卫把你过去12小时没见过的妻子带进了面试室。你经过她身边时，可以摸摸她的手。你见到她很高兴，因为你们被分开了，你根本不知道发生了什么。
So, where are my children? I don't know, sir. I'm sure they'll be fine. Your wife goes through a similar interview, but she keeps being confronted about the answers she's giving because they're different from yours. And the officer can't understand why this story varies so differently between two people who experienced it.
那么，我的孩子们在哪里？我不知道，先生。我相信他们会没事的。你的妻子经历了类似的面试，但她不断被质问她的回答，因为它们和你的不一样。官员无法理解为什么两个经历过它的人的故事会有如此大的差异。
Half an hour passes before her children are brought into the room. And then the officer has to talk to a 10-year-old boy about whatever his parents said and then confront the 10-year-old boy on inconsistencies between his story and his parents' story. And then the wife is like, when am I going to see my husband again? And the officer is like, I have no idea. Let them know if you need to use the bathroom.
过了半小时，她的孩子被带进了房间。然后官员不得不和一个10岁的小男孩谈论他父母所说的一切，然后就他的故事和他父母故事之间的不一致质问那个10岁的小男孩。然后妻子问，我什么时候能再见到我丈夫？官员说，我不知道。如果你需要上厕所，让他们知道。
Ursula made the case that the families shouldn't get sent back to Mexico. And to her shock, her supervisor agreed. In fact, she happened to walk outside the moment the family got released. They've got their backpacks on. They're holding hands. She thought, maybe this won't be so bad.
厄休拉提出不应该把这些家庭送回墨西哥。令她震惊的是，她的主管同意了。事实上，她恰好在那个家庭被释放的那一刻走到外面。他们背着背包。他们手牵着手。她想，也许这不会那么糟糕。
But that was the last time. The very next interview, a woman told her over and over she was afraid of being raped and killed in Mexico. Ursula believed she was going back to a place where that was very possible. But because the woman couldn't name a specific person who'd assault her, Ursula had to send her back. Since then it's essentially been no after no after no.
但那是最后一次。下一次面试，一个女人反复告诉她，她害怕在墨西哥被强奸和杀害。厄休拉相信她会回到一个非常有这种可能的地方。但因为这个女人说不出具体是谁要袭击她，厄休拉不得不把她送回去。从那以后，基本上就是不断的拒绝，不断的拒绝。
Asylum officers told me that even when they find one of those unicorn cases, where they check off all the boxes and recommend not returning to Mexico, their supervisors overrule them. Anne told me and my producer, Nadia Reiman, about one asylum seeker's case where their attacker even spelled out their motive, and it still didn't fly.
庇护官员告诉我，即使他们发现了那些“独角兽”案例，即他们勾选了所有方框并建议不要返回墨西哥，他们的主管也会否决他们。安妮告诉我和我的制片人纳迪亚·雷曼，关于一个寻求庇护者的案例，他们的攻击者甚至拼出了他们的动机，但这仍然行不通。
It was basically a situation where there was a really clear connection to the nationality. Like, the persecutor had, like, really said, like, I am harming you because of this nationality-- your nationality. And the harm was really, really severe. It was like, definitely torture. And it was really clear that the police, like, weren't going to do a thing about it, didn't care at all. And the supervisor rejected it.
那基本上是一个与国籍有非常明确联系的情况。就像，迫害者确实说过，我因为这个国籍——你的国籍——而伤害你。这种伤害真的非常严重。就像，绝对是折磨。而且非常清楚，警察根本不管，根本不在乎。主管拒绝了它。
Why? Did they say why?
为什么？他们说为什么了吗？
They said, we can't show that if this individual went back to Mexico the persecutor would be able to locate them.
他们说，我们无法证明如果这个人回到墨西哥，迫害者能否找到他们。
So the standard today is upside down from what it used to be under credible fear. Instead of, let's err on the side of letting people in because we don't want anyone to be tortured or die, under MPP, the standard is almost impossibly high, so almost nobody gets in. The Department of Homeland Security says only about 960 people interviewed have not been sent back to Mexico.
他的老板惊呆了。他似乎真的不知道该说什么。最后他告诉他，他可能不得不以某种方式处分他，启动纪律处分程序。道格那天晚上回家后决定升级这件事。他回到他的便笺纸前。
Ultimately, of a little more than 47,000 MPP cases registered as of October, with about 37,000 of those still pending-- of those, only 11 people have been granted asylum or some other kind of relief, according to Syracuse University, which tracks all this using government statistics. 11.
最终，截至10月登记的47000多起MPP案件中，约有37000起仍在审理中——根据追踪所有这些政府统计数据的雪城大学，其中只有11人获得了庇护或其他形式的救济。11人。
And that's what the policy was meant to do. The administration credits MPP for a sharp drop in the numbers coming to the border. Mark Morgan, the acting head of Customs and Border Protection, calls it a game changer and absolutely successful.
这就是这项政策的目的。本届政府将边境人数的急剧下降归功于MPP。海关及边境保护局代理局长马克·摩根称其为“游戏规则改变者”，并且绝对成功。
It only took Doug two days and five interviews to go home after work and pull out the law books. He's a lawyer. He actually owned a beat-up copy of the Immigration and Nationality Act-- the law, hundreds of pages long, that makes up the foundation of the US immigration system. He grabbed that off his bedroom shelf, along with a few of his other books from law school. He printed out a bunch of court cases and Supreme Court decisions with more cases pulled up on his computer screen. In the middle of all of this was his pen and white legal pad.
道格只用了两天时间和五次面试，下班回家后就翻出了法律书籍。他是一名律师。他实际上拥有一本破旧的《移民与国籍法》——这部法律有数百页，构成了美国移民系统的基石。他从书架上抓起那本书，以及他在法学院时的其他几本书。他打印出了一堆法院判例和最高法院裁决，电脑屏幕上还打开了更多案件。所有这些中间是他的一支笔和一张白色便笺纸。
As an attorney, he wanted to get his feelings about MPP, how much worse it felt compared to everything else they did, down in writing. He worked for hours, and he wrote down seven bullet points-- the main ways he thought MPP was illegal. Once he saw the list laid out there on the lined white paper, Doug knew what to do. The next day, he went to tell his supervisor he wasn't going to do any more MPP interviews.
作为一名律师，他想写下他对MPP的感受，即它与其他他们做的一切相比感觉有多糟糕。他工作了几个小时，写下了七个要点——他认为MPP非法的最主要方式。一旦他看到那些列在划线白纸上的清单，道格就知道该做什么了。第二天，他去告诉主管，他不会再做任何MPP面试了。
His response was, I know these interviews are hard. We're all required to do them. That's why were trying to spread it out. It's, you know, on rolling basis, et cetera, et cetera. And, you know, at that point, there was like this moment where I could have just said, "You're right, I know this sucks," and gone back.
他的回应是，我知道这些面试很困难。我们都被要求做。这就是为什么我们试图分散开来。你知道，这是滚动进行的，等等，等等。那时候，有一个瞬间，我本可以只是说，“你是对的，我知道这很糟糕，”然后回去继续做。
And I paused. And I told him, you don't understand. I'm not doing these interviews. And he looked at me. He's like, what do you-- you're not doing these interviews? And I was like, no. I was like, I think they're illegal, they're definitely immoral, and I'm not doing them.
但我停顿了一下。我告诉他，你不明白。我不会做这些面试。他看着我。他说，你什么——你不做这些面试？我说，不。我说，我认为它们是不合法的，它们绝对是不道德的，我不会做它们。
His boss was stunned. He didn't really seem to know what to say. Eventually he told him he was probably going to have to write him up somehow, to start disciplinary proceedings. Doug went home that night and decided to escalate. He went back to his legal pad.
他的老板惊呆了，似乎不知道该说什么好。最终他告诉道格，他可能不得不以某种方式给他记过，启动纪律处分程序。那天晚上道格回到家，决定升级事态。他又拿起了他的记事本。
I essentially wrote a legal memo explaining all of the reasons that I thought it was illegal and why I was refusing to do it. And then on that Monday, I emailed that to all of the administration in San Francisco and the two supervisors that were involved in the disciplinary proceedings.
我本质上写了一份法律备忘录，解释了我认为它非法的全部理由，以及我为什么要拒绝做它。然后在那周一，我把那份文件发邮件给了旧金山的所有管理层以及参与纪律处分程序的两名主管。
And then, nothing. Nothing happened. Instead of sparking some kind of rebellion, or at least forcing a confrontation, it's crickets. So he took it a step further. He sent his memo to a senator's office. Then he drafted his goodbye email, attached his memo, and sent it out office-wide to all of San Francisco Asylum, about 80 people, and to a representative of the union for asylum officers across the country. And with that, Doug shut down his work computer and walked out. He quit.
然后，什么也没有发生。什么都没有发生。并没有引发某种反抗，或者至少强迫一次对峙，反而一片寂静。所以他更进一步。他把备忘录发给了参议员办公室。然后他起草了他的告别邮件，附上了备忘录，并把它发给了整个旧金山庇护办公室，大约80人，以及全国庇护官员工会的代表。就这样，道格关掉了他的工作电脑，走了出去。他辞职了。
They make one change, and everyone at the office is like, oh, this is terrible, but we'll figure it out. And they make another change. And you're like, oh, this is terrible. But I need my job. I'm going to do it, even if I don't want to, and I'll complain about it. And I'll complain about the work, and I'll complain about the hours.
他们做了一个改变，办公室里每个人都说，哦，这很糟糕，但我们会解决的。他们又做了一个改变。你就说，哦，这很糟糕。但我需要我的工作。我会做的，即使我不想做，我会抱怨它。我会抱怨工作，我会抱怨时间。
At the end of the day, I'm going to do it. And the more I do it, the easier it is to do. And that is terrifying. I mean, that's how all the awful things in the world have happened. That's how you get so many good people doing really bad things. And that's what's happening, and it's terrifying. You're, like, literally sending people back to be raped and killed. That's what this is.
到头来，我还是会做。我做得越多，就越容易做。这太可怕了。我的意思是，这就是世界上所有可怕事情发生的方式。这就是为什么有那么多好人在做坏事。这就是正在发生的事情，太可怕了。你简直是在把人送回去被强奸和杀害。这就是它的本质。
The three officers I spoke with are not alone. A union representing the asylum officers and USCIS employees filed a brief in a lawsuit against the administration, arguing that MPP was illegal. And a ton of officers are quitting. I've heard this from a bunch of people in the asylum corps and at Citizenship and Immigration Services, the parent agency. Several use the word "exodus." And if officers can't quit, they're calling in sick-- anything they can do to avoid MPP interviews.
我采访的三名官员并不孤单。一个代表庇护官员和美国公民及移民服务局员工的工会提交了一份简报，诉讼挑战本届政府，认为MPP是不合法的。很多官员正在辞职。我从庇护部门和公民及移民服务局（其母机构）的一群人那里听到了这一点。几个人用了“出走”这个词。如果官员不能辞职，他们就请病假——任何他们能做的来避免MPP面试的方法。
We tried to get some numbers from the government. They wouldn't tell us how many people had left. They did say that by the end of the year, they hope to have 771 asylum officers. But as of a month ago, they had something like 550, meaning they're roughly 200 people short. I tried to get an interview with the acting head of USCIS, Ken Cuccinelli, to talk about all this. He's since been named Deputy Homeland Security Secretary. He didn't give us one, but I did get one question in. It was at a press breakfast, so this audio was recorded on my phone.
我们试图从政府那里得到一些数字。他们不告诉我们有多少人离开了。但他们确实说，到年底，他们希望有771名庇护官员。但一个月前，他们只有大约550人，这意味着他们缺少大约200人。我试图采访美国公民及移民服务局代理局长肯·库奇内利来谈论这一切。他此后被任命为国土安全部副部长。他没有接受采访，但我还是问了一个问题。那是在新闻早餐会上，所以这段录音是在我的手机上录的。
All right. Molly O'Toole from the Los Angeles Times.
好吧。来自《洛杉矶时报》的莫莉·奥图尔。
How do you answer the concerns from some of your asylum officers? There are concerns that many of these policies being handed down by the Trump administration, particularly targeting asylum, are in fact illegal, that they're being ordered to implement policies that are in direct contradiction with immigration laws that are passed by Congress.
你如何回答来自一些庇护官员的担忧？有人担心特朗普政府传达的许多政策，特别是针对庇护的政策，实际上是不合法的，他们被命令实施与国会通过的移民法直接矛盾的政策。
Well, they're not in direct contradiction, or we wouldn't be utilizing them. We have 19,000 people that work with USCIS. I don't expect any two of us to completely agree on all of this. But I do expect that the professional employees at USCIS will implement the policies in place. They're part of the--
嗯，它们并没有直接矛盾，否则我们就不会使用它们了。我们在美国公民及移民服务局有19000名员工。我不指望我们中有任何两个人能完全同意所有这一切。但我确实期望美国公民及移民服务局的专业员工会执行现行的政策。它们是——
They're part of the executive branch, he said. And so long as we're in the position of putting in place what we believe to be legal policies that haven't been found to be otherwise, we fully expect them to implement those faithfully and sincerely and vigorously.
他说，它们是行政分支的一部分。只要我们处于实施我们认为是合法且尚未被发现不是的政策的立场，我们完全期望他们忠诚、真诚、有力地实施这些政策。
Now we're just shy of MPP's first birthday. After a chaotic start, it's thousands returned each week. It's expanded all the way east across the US border, from California to Texas' Gulf Coast. And it's not just Central Americans being pushed back. Now it's Cubans, Venezuelans, pregnant women, LGBTQ. Asylum, at least at the southern border, has essentially ground to a halt. Here's Anne.
现在MPP即将迎来一周年。经过混乱的开始，现在每周有数千人被遣返。它已经从加利福尼亚州一直扩展到得克萨斯州的墨西哥湾沿岸，横跨美国整个边境。被推回的不仅仅是中美洲人。现在还有古巴人、委内瑞拉人、孕妇、LGBTQ群体。庇护，至少在南部边境，基本上已经陷入停滞。安妮来了。
I'll say this. Like, the administration's been successful.
我想说这一点。这个政府是成功的。
What do you mean?
你什么意思？
They want negative decisions. They don't want asylum seekers in this country. They don't want people to get positive decisions or determinations for asylum. They have felt that the standards for screening interviews were too low, and they wanted those standards changed and those standards raised, and they've succeeded.
他们想要负面的决定。他们不希望寻求庇护者在这个国家。他们不希望人们得到庇护的正面决定或认定。他们认为甄别面试的标准太低了，他们想改变这些标准，提高这些标准，他们做到了。
What do you think the administration's end goal is?
你认为政府的最终目标是什么？
No more people from shit hole countries.
不再需要来自“糟糕国家”的人。
Anne throws up in the shower almost every day. She has recurring nightmares. She says she can't focus, can't sleep. She thinks about the people she's returned to Mexico all the time. It's nearly 100. But there's one family in particular that she can't stop thinking about-- a father and son.
安妮几乎每天在淋浴时都会呕吐。她做着反复出现的噩梦。她说她无法集中注意力，无法入睡。她一直想着那些被她送回墨西哥的人。几乎有100个。但有一个家庭让她特别无法释怀——一对父子。
Why do you think that case sticks with you?
为什么你认为那个案例一直困扰着你？
The kid was really young. What happened to him? Did his kid get kidnapped? Did he get murdered? It's happening. It's happening a lot.
孩子真的很小。他发生了什么？他被绑架了吗？他被谋杀了？这正在发生。正在频繁发生。
What was the--
那是——
And then, what's my moral culpability in that? I interviewed that case, and my signature's on that paperwork. And that's something now that I live with. So yeah, I feel-- I feel in some ways that this administration's made me a human rights abuser.
在那件事上，我的道德责任是什么？我面试了那个案例，文件上有我的签名。现在那是我生活中无法抹去的一部分。所以是的，我感到——在某种程度上，我觉得这个政府把我变成了一个侵犯人权者。
The irony of this policy is that under our asylum law, to qualify for asylum, you have to have been harmed because you're part of a particular group, a certain class of people. And the way that the asylum officers have implemented MPP, they've created exactly that-- a huge group of people in need of protection, about 60,000 migrants forced by the US back to Mexico to be preyed upon there, as they wait on their request for safety in the US. It's exactly the sort of situation that our law was supposed to prevent.
这项政策的讽刺之处在于，根据我们的庇护法，要获得庇护资格，你必须因为属于特定群体、特定类别的人而受到伤害。而庇护官员实施MPP的方式，恰恰创造了这一点——一个巨大的需要保护的群体，约6万名移民被美国强行遣返回墨西哥，并在那里等待他们在美国的庇护请求时沦为猎物。这正是我们法律本应防止的情况。
One asylum officer told me, it's the first time that we've been asked to affirmatively do harm to people. You're not just saying, I don't think you're eligible. You're literally saying, I believe what you're saying, I think you're in danger. Go back to that danger.
一位庇护官员告诉我，这是我们第一次被要求主动地去伤害人们。你不仅仅是在说，我不认为你符合条件。你实际上是在说，我相信你所说的话，我认为你处于危险之中。回到那个危险中去吧。
Molly O'Toole covers immigration for the Los Angeles Times. She wrote a print version of this story, also. It's at their website.
莫莉·奥图尔为《洛杉矶时报》报道移民新闻。她也写了这个故事的印刷版。在他们的网站上。
By the way, in the wake of her story, USCIS started a hunt to figure out who talked to her and to us and issued warnings to asylum agents not to speak with the press about what is happening inside the agency.
顺便说一下，在她的报道之后，美国公民及移民服务局开始搜查是谁和她以及我们谈话，并向庇护官员发出警告，不得与媒体谈论机构内部正在发生的事情。
Coming up, what's it sound like when the cartels get on the phone and bargain with your family for your life? We have recordings. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，当贩毒集团打电话来并为了你的生命与你的家人讨价还价时，那听起来是什么样的？我们有录音。从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "The Out Crowd," stories about the people, the tens of thousands of them, who have been pushed into Mexico by the president's Remain in Mexico policy and other policies. We're talking about what happens to those people as they wait in Mexico for months. We're rerunning this episode today because it just won the first Pulitzer ever given for audio journalism in the Pulitzer's 100-plus year history.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目，“局外人”，讲述的是那些人，成千上万的人，他们被总统的“留在墨西哥”政策和其他政策推入了墨西哥。我们讨论的是那些人在墨西哥等待数月时会发生什么。我们今天重播这集，因为它刚刚获得了普利策奖100多年历史上第一个音频新闻奖。
And we have arrived at Act two of our program. Act two is about the danger that these asylum seekers face when they're sent back to Mexico. Act Two, "Take the Long Way Home."
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕是关于这些寻求庇护者在被送回墨西哥时面临的危险。第二幕，“走远路回家。”
If you had to pick which border city in Mexico is the most dangerous, Nuevo Laredo, right across the border from Laredo, Texas, would be a good contender. The State Department classifies it as a level four threat. That is the same threat level as Iraq and Syria.
如果你必须选择墨西哥哪个边境城市最危险，新拉雷多，就在得克萨斯州拉雷多对面，将是一个很好的竞争者。国务院将其归类为四级威胁。那与伊拉克和叙利亚的威胁等级相同。
And a lot of danger there is kidnapping. Kidnapping is so prevalent there that one of our producers met men in a migrant shelter who were terrified to go outside. A young Cuban guy told her, just putting one foot outside the shelter makes him worried. A trip of just two minutes, he's looking all around, and he's scared.
那里很大一部分危险是绑架。绑架在那里非常普遍，我们的一位制片人在一个移民收容所遇到了不敢外出的男人。一个古巴年轻人告诉她，只要跨出收容所一步就让他担心。哪怕只是两分钟的路程，他都要环顾四周，感到害怕。
We're interested in these kidnappings because they're so common. Reporter Emily Green went to Nuevo Laredo in August. She has this story about one kidnapping and what happened to one family, including recordings and details you really never get to hear. This family ended up in Nuevo Laredo because of MPP. Here's Emily.
我们对这些绑架感兴趣，因为它们太常见了。记者艾米丽·格林于8月去了新拉雷多。她有一个关于一起绑架案以及一个家庭遭遇的故事，包括你从未听说过的录音和细节。这个家庭因为MPP最终留在了新拉雷多。艾米丽来了。
This guy who got kidnapped I met him by chance-- actually, before he got kidnapped. And he told me how scared he was that he would get kidnapped. I was on a bridge in Nuevo Laredo that connects Mexico to the US. Every day around 1:00 PM that month, the US was sending back migrants from the US side to Mexico under MPP.
这个被绑架的家伙，我是在偶然的情况下遇到他的——实际上，在他被绑架之前。他告诉我他有多害怕会被绑架。当时我在新拉雷多的一座桥上，那是连接墨西哥和美国的桥梁。那个月每天下午1点左右，美国都会在MPP政策下将移民从美国一侧送回墨西哥。
That day there were a hundred of them. They were easy to spot, they all carried clear plastic bags with a couple of documents in them, and none of them had shoelaces. US immigration takes shoelaces from anyone they detain.
那天有一百人。他们很容易辨认，他们都拿着透明塑料袋，里面有几份文件，而且他们都没有鞋带。美国移民局会收缴他们拘留的任何人的鞋带。
Most of them were men, many of them with their heads down. And one pair stands out to me, a father and son in matching polo shirts, both of them sweating in the heat. They're chubby, soft faces. Dad has his arm around son. They seem like they'll talk to me. The man-- I'll call him David-- quickly tells me a story.
大多数是男人，许多人低着头。有一对父子引起了我的注意，穿着配套的马球衫，都在热浪中出汗。他们有着圆润、柔和的脸。父亲把手臂搭在儿子身上。他们看起来会和我交谈。那个男人——我叫他大卫——很快告诉我一个故事。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
He says he's not a criminal. He's a person who's always made a living. But he can't live in his country anymore. They're from Honduras. David was a businessman. He ran a little clothing store. The gangs there demand money. They call it a war tax. The tax kept getting higher and higher until David's family couldn't pay it anymore. One night, the cartel broke into his house, threatened to rape his daughter, and so they fled.
他说他不是罪犯。他是一个一直靠双手赚钱的人。但他再也不能待在他的国家了。他们来自洪都拉斯。大卫是个商人。他经营一家小服装店。那里的帮派要求钱。他们称之为“战争税”。税收越来越高，直到大卫的家人再也付不起了。一天晚上，贩毒集团闯进他家，威胁要强奸他的女儿，于是他们逃跑了。
[SOBBING]
[抽泣]
I've done lots of interviews with people like David, migrants in really difficult situations. This one felt especially hard. I think just seeing a father fall apart in front of his 11-year-old son--
我采访过很多像大卫这样的人，处于极其困难处境的移民。这一次感觉格外困难。我想，仅仅是看到一个父亲在他11岁的儿子面前崩溃——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
David says he wanted to ask for asylum in the US, but the agents didn't listen to him. They just gave him documents to come back to a court date in December. He can't go back to Honduras, he says.
大卫说他想在美国申请庇护，但官员们根本没听他的。他们只是给了他文件让他回墨西哥等待12月的庭审日期。他说，他不能回到洪都拉斯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I don't have anywhere to go. I don't have anything. I don't have money, he says. They say that here, where we're being sent, a lot of people get kidnapped, and I don't know what to do. We only talked for 10 minutes. I ended up lending him my phone. He called his sister in New Jersey and explained what happened-- that he made it to the United States only to be sent back to Mexico.
他说，我无处可去。我什么都没有。我没有钱。他们说在这里，我们被送到的地方，很多人被绑架，我不知道该怎么办。我们只谈了10分钟。我最后借给了他我的电话。他打电话给他在新泽西的姐姐，解释了发生了什么——他到了美国却被送回了墨西哥。
It was getting dark out, and I'd been told not to stay in Nuevo Laredo past dusk. I crossed back into the US to go to dinner, probably not a mile away from where I had last seen David. And my phone rang. It was David's sister. I'll call her Laura. She had my number because it was my phone he called her from earlier today. She was crying so hard I struggled to understand what she was saying. She tells me David and his son had been kidnapped just hours after I left them. She had gotten a call from a cartel demanding ransom.
天黑了，我被告知不要在天黑后留在新拉雷多。我回到了美国去吃晚饭，离我上次见到大卫的地方可能不到一英里。我的电话响了。是大卫的姐姐。我叫她劳拉。她有我的号码，因为他早些时候是用我的电话打给她的。她哭得太厉害了，我很难听懂她在说什么。她告诉我，就在我离开他们几小时后，大卫和他的儿子就被绑架了。她接到了一个贩毒集团要求赎金的电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Laura says that the cartel told her the ransom was $9,000 for David and another $9,000 for his son, so $18,000 total. They put David on the phone briefly so she knew he was alive, and then the kidnappers got on.
劳拉说，贩毒集团告诉她赎金是大卫9000美元，儿子9000美元，总共18000美元。他们简短地让大卫接了电话，以便她知道他还活着，然后绑架者接管了电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
OK.
好的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
And I told them, where in the world are we going to get this money? The man on the other end told her she had to get the money. He said he'd call back tomorrow. I asked Laura to record the phone calls.
我告诉他们，我们到底去哪弄这笔钱？另一端的人告诉她她必须弄到钱。他说他明天会再打来。我让劳拉录下电话。
Bueno.
喂。
And she did. When they called the next day, she put them on speaker and used a relative's phone to shoot video of it.
她录了。第二天他们打电话时，她打开了免提，并用亲戚的手机拍摄了视频。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
They tell her, I need you to deposit the money as soon as possible, viejita. Viejita means "old lady." Laura is 38. She tells them again that she has no money, that she's sick from anxiety. In her conversations with me, Laura is scared, crying. But when she talks to the kidnappers, she holds it together. She asks if David and her son are OK. The kidnappers tell her, they have food, that they can bathe, for now. Each call only lasts a few minutes.
他们告诉她，我需要你尽快存钱，老太婆。“老太婆”指“老女人”。劳拉才38岁。她再次告诉他们她没有钱，她因为焦虑而生病。在与我的谈话中，劳拉感到害怕、哭泣。但当她与绑架者交谈时，她保持镇定。她问大卫和她儿子还好吗。绑架者告诉她，他们有食物，可以洗澡，目前还可以。每次通话只持续几分钟。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
By the third day, the cartel has lowered the price to $5,000 each for David and his son. Laura works the night shift at a printing factory in New Jersey, hardly makes $20,000 in a year. Plus, she's a single mom.
到了第三天，贩毒集团将大卫和他儿子的价格降到了每人5000美元。劳拉在新泽西的一家印刷厂上夜班，一年几乎挣不到20000美元。而且，她是一位单身母亲。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
In all of these calls, the kidnappers talk super fast-- I'm guessing because they have other ransom calls to make. Kidnapping's a big business, a volume business, with a whole infrastructure. Kidnapping migrants has been common in Mexico for a long time. What's different now is that the US is making it especially easy for the cartels to identify and snatch victims. They're sending asylum seekers back in big groups, all at once, same time each day. And they're easy to identify with their plastic bags and missing shoelaces.
在所有这些电话中，绑架者说得超级快——我猜是因为他们还有其他勒索电话要打。绑架是一门大生意，量大的生意，有完整的产业链。在墨西哥，绑架移民早已司空见惯。现在的不同之处在于，美国使得贩毒集团更容易识别和劫持受害者。他们每天在同一时间大批地将寻求庇护者送回。而且通过他们的塑料袋和缺失的鞋带很容易识别。
Homeland Security didn't respond to my request for comment on the kidnapping situation. But this week, the acting head of Customs and Border Protection said the US is, quote, "sending a message to the criminal organizations to stop exploiting these migrants." In Nuevo Laredo, the most dangerous part of these asylum seekers' journey is probably the hours right after they've been sent back to Mexico. After walking across the bridge, they're transported to the Mexican Immigration Office by van. Outside the office, men in four-door trucks monitor who's coming and going. Locals call them, Los Malos-- the bad guys. One migrant told me about getting chased as he walked to a shelter from there.
国土安全部没有回应我对绑架情况置评的请求。但本周，海关及边境保护局代理局长表示，美国正在，“向犯罪组织发出信号，停止剥削这些移民。”在新拉雷多，这些寻求庇护者旅程中最危险的部分可能是被送回墨西哥后的几小时。走过大桥后，他们被货车运送到墨西哥移民局。在办公室外，开着四门卡车的人监控着来往的人。当地人叫他们“恶人”。一位移民告诉我他在那里步行去收容所时被追赶。
But by far, the most dangerous place is a bus station. It's a place they go to escape Nuevo Laredo, but it's a place they end up getting caught. Kidnapping is so routine, the cartels refer to it as passing through the office. On the extortion calls, you can tell it's a well-oiled machine. It's methodical. They sound like they're negotiating the price of a car. They do this all the time.
但到目前为止，最危险的地方是汽车站。那是他们逃离新拉雷多的地方，但也是他们最终被捕的地方。绑架太常规了，贩毒集团称其为“过办公室”。在勒索电话中，你可以听出这是一个运作良好的机器。有条不紊。他们听起来就像在商量车的价格。他们一直在做这件事。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Laura turns to everyone she can think of. She goes to her local police department and to her mayor's office to ask for help. They reach out to the Office of Senator Cory Booker. But by the time they get back to her, about a week later, it's too late. Laura eventually scrapes together money from her mom and sister, but just a fraction of what the cartel is asking for.
劳拉转向她能想到的每一个人。她去了当地警察局和市长办公室寻求帮助。他们联系了参议员科里·布克的办公室。但当他们一周后给她反馈时，已经太晚了。劳拉最终从她妈妈和姐姐那里凑够了钱，但这只是贩毒集团要求的一小部分。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
She tells them, look, I've already pulled together $1,200. Tell me what we're going to do, and give me time to get the rest. The man says he'll confer with his boss. In the meantime, he says, she should wire the money.
她告诉他们，听着，我已经凑齐了1200美元。告诉我我们要怎么做，给我时间去凑剩下的。那个人说他会和老板商量。同时，他说，她应该汇钱。
Laura asks to talk to her brother, and they put him on.
劳拉要求和她弟弟说话，他们让他接了电话。
Hello?
喂？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
No, no. No, [SPEAKING SPANISH].
不，不。不，[讲西班牙语]。
She asked David, how are you, brother? Worried, he says. She tells him, don't worry, that she's pulled together some money. The next day, the cartels release David and his son. I talked to David on the phone three days after his release. He's so distressed, it's hard for him to finish a sentence.
她问大卫，你还好吗，弟弟？他说很担心。她告诉他，别担心，她已经凑到了一些钱。第二天，贩毒集团释放了大卫和他的儿子。在大卫获释三天后，我通过电话和他谈过。他非常痛苦，以至于难以完成一句话。
[SOBBING]
[抽泣]
Respira. Respira. Respira.
呼吸。呼吸。呼吸。
Breathe, I tell him. I wanted to help him. That's not something a reporter is supposed to say. But back when they were kidnapped, their lives were in immediate danger. And I helped in small ways. I connected Laura with an NGO in Mexico City that advocates for migrants. Since David and his son were released, I've suggested safe bus options.
我告诉他，呼吸。我想帮助他。这不是记者应该说的话。但当他们被绑架时，他们的生命处于直接危险之中。我尽了绵薄之力。我将劳拉与墨西哥城的一个倡导移民的非政府组织联系起来。自从大卫和他的儿子获释后，我建议了安全的乘车方式。
The family, they always knew that I was a reporter doing a story on them. But they came to see me as one of the few people they could trust, that they could rely on. Laura called me almost every day with updates. She still does.
那个家庭，他们一直知道我是个记者在写他们的故事。但他们开始视我为他们可以信任、可以依赖的少数人之一。劳拉几乎每天都打电话给我报告最新情况。她现在仍然这样。
A few weeks ago, I went to meet David and his family in Monterrey in northern Mexico, where they were holed up. They were staying with an acquaintance of Laura's in exchange for grocery money and help with construction. David didn't want us interviewing him there. He feels his welcome has run out. So we do the interview at our hotel.
几周前，我前往墨西哥北部的蒙特雷见大卫和他的家人，他们躲在那里。他们住在劳拉的一个熟人家里，换取杂货钱和建筑帮助。大卫不想让我们在那里采访他。他觉得他已经不受欢迎了。所以我们在酒店进行采访。
It's David, his 11-year-old son, and his 19-year-old daughter, who's also been sent back to Mexico under MPP. I'm here with my producer, Lina. We figure, we'll talk to David in one room while the kids watch TV in the other. But the kids sit by their dad on the bed. They won't leave one another's side.
那是大卫、他11岁的儿子和他19岁的女儿，她也被MPP政策遣返回了墨西哥。我和我的制片人莉娜在那里。我们想，我们可以让孩子在另一个房间看电视，同时采访大卫。但孩子们坐在父亲旁边的床上。他们不愿离开对方。
I wanted to know what happened when I left him that day on the bridge. And what he described were all these details of how the cartel's kidnapping business actually works once you're a victim on the inside-- details that were routine, and also terrifying.
我想知道那天我在桥上离开他后发生了什么。他所描述的都是关于贩毒集团的绑架生意在内部运作时的一些细节——那些例行公事，但也令人恐惧的细节。
So here's what happened. He said, he and the other hundred people who were sent back to Mexico that day were taken from the bridge to the local immigration office for processing. After that, he says a man wearing a Mexican immigration officer uniform agreed to take him and his son to the bus station so they could go to a safer city. But as soon as they got to the station, he got a bad feeling.
事情是这样的。他说，那天被送回墨西哥的一百人从桥上被带到当地移民局进行处理。在那之后，他说一名穿着墨西哥移民官制服的男人同意带他和他的儿子去汽车站，这样他们就可以去一个更安全的城市。但当他们到达车站时，他有了一种不好的预感。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
When I went in with my son, this guy grabbed me. It was a tall guy, strong, full of tattoos. So he grabbed me and he said, I want to talk to you. And I said, I have nothing to talk to you about. And he said, you're going to get into that car, and we're going to ask you some questions. And I said, no. And he said, you can get into the car the easy way or the hard way.
当我和儿子进去时，这家伙抓住了我。那是个高大的家伙，很强壮，满身纹身。他抓住我，说，我想和你谈谈。我说，我没什么和你谈的。他说，你得上那辆车，我们要问你几个问题。我说，不。他说，你可以轻松地进车，也可以困难地进车。
He says at least a dozen migrants also arrived at the bus station that night. And the cartel hustled them into different trucks. All the trucks were brand new, he says. He remembers that the one he got into was a gray Nissan, and there were four or five other migrants in there with him. He says the immigration officer who drove him to the bus station sat in his car and watched them all being carted off.
他说那天晚上至少还有十二名移民到达汽车站。贩毒集团把他们塞进不同的卡车里。所有卡车都是崭新的，他说。他记得他上的那辆是灰色的尼桑，里面还有其他四五个移民。他说那个带他去汽车站的移民官坐在车里看着他们全被带走。
We can't confirm this, but there is a long history of law enforcement and the cartels working hand-in-hand. For example, in 2011, seven top officials at Mexico's immigration agency were fired amid allegations that the agency was involved in the kidnapping of migrants. And it squares with what his sister in New Jersey told me.
我们无法证实这一点，但执法部门与贩毒集团携手合作由来已久。例如，2011年，墨西哥移民局的七名高官被解职，原因是指控该机构参与了绑架移民。这与他在新泽西的姐姐告诉我的情况相符。
She wired money to that immigration officer for David's bus ticket. And when she got the ransom call, the kidnappers told her to wire the money to that same account-- the one the immigration officer used. She said something like, isn't that the immigration officer's account? And they hung up.
她汇钱给那个移民官支付大卫的车票。当她接到赎金电话时，绑架者告诉她汇钱到那个账户——移民官使用的那个账户。她说，那不是移民官的账户吗？然后他们就挂断了电话。
I asked the Mexican immigration agency to respond. They told me they have no knowledge of recent complaints of immigration officers turning migrants over to the cartels. In the truck, David held onto his son. The kidnappers didn't speak.
我要求墨西哥移民局作出回应。他们告诉我，他们不知道最近有关于移民官将移民交给贩毒集团的投诉。在卡车里，大卫紧紧抓住他的儿子。绑架者没说话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
The guy just told us to keep our heads down, to stop looking at the sides. And the guy who was driving us was keeping an eye on us, and he was making sure we were not chatting. They had the windows all rolled up.
那家伙只是告诉我们低下头，不要往两侧看。开车的那家伙一直盯着我们，确保我们没有闲聊。他们把窗户都关上了。
The truck drove around for a while, but David suspects they were just going in circles, that they didn't actually travel very far. They pulled up to a normal-looking house with a big gate. Inside, the kidnappers used their cell phone to take pictures of David, his son, and the rest. They interrogated David about where he's from, his line of work, how he got to the US, and, most importantly, what family members he has there. It was like patient intake at a health clinic, except for by a cartel.
卡车转了一会儿，但大卫怀疑他们只是在兜圈子，并没有走远。他们驶向一栋看起来很普通的房子，带有一个大门。在里面，绑架者用手机拍下了大卫、他的儿子和其他人的照片。他们审问大卫他来自哪里，从事什么职业，如何到达美国，最重要的是，他在那里有什么家庭成员。就像诊所的病人入院，只不过是贩毒集团做的。
We talk about the cartels as organized crime, but I never imagined the bookkeeping. They keep records and photos of the migrants they kidnap, and also who they release. David says that there were more than 20 migrants at the house. The men and women slept in separate rooms. During the day, the kidnappers hit any of the men who tried to look at the women. The room David and his son slept in had one mattress. Everyone else slept on the floor. At night, David would lay on the ground, holding his son.
我们谈论贩毒集团是有组织犯罪，但我从未想象过那种记账方式。他们保存着被绑架者的记录和照片，以及释放人员的记录。大卫说屋子里有20多名移民。男女分住不同的房间。白天，绑架者殴打任何试图看女人的男人。大卫和儿子住的房间只有一张床垫。其他人都睡在地板上。晚上，大卫睡在地上，抱着儿子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I would lay down with him in a corner, and I would hug my son. They couldn't see you crying, but my tears were almost, like, falling out. What hurt me the most, Emily, was that when this guy arrived, the boss, he would always tell me that my son's organs were good for selling, that he was in a good age that he was only 11 years old. And my son once heard the guy saying that his kidneys, that his organs, were good for selling. And he was almost crying. And I told him, don't cry. But I was desperate.
我会和他躺在角落里，拥抱我的儿子。他们看不到你哭，但我的眼泪几乎要掉下来了。艾米丽，最让我痛苦的是，当这个家伙，那个老板到达时，他总是告诉我我儿子的器官可以卖钱，他正值好年龄，才11岁。我儿子曾听到那个家伙说他的肾脏、他的器官可以卖钱。他差点哭了。我告诉他，别哭。但我绝望了。
As David tells me this story, his two kids are still sitting on the bed beside him. Neither of them is looking at anything in particular. They're just sitting there, blankly. David also seems devoid of emotion. He doesn't at all resemble the David from a few weeks ago, the one I talked to right after his release. Now his affect is completely flat.
当大卫告诉我这个故事时，他的两个孩子仍坐在他身边的床上。他们谁也没在看什么特别的东西。只是呆滞地坐着。大卫似乎也失去了情感。他一点也不像几周前的大卫，那个我在他获释后采访的大卫。现在他的神情完全麻木。
On the fourth day of his kidnapping, one of the bosses woke David up and told him they'd reached a deal with his sister.
在绑架的第四天，老板之一叫醒大卫，告诉他他们已经和他的姐姐达成协议。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
And he said to me, get up with your son, fat guy, because today I'm going to release you guys because your sister already paid, made a deposit.
他对我说了，和你的儿子起来，胖子，因为今天我要释放你们，因为你姐姐已经付了钱，存了款。
The man told David if he talked to anyone-- police, reporters-- the cartel would come for him, take his son, and kill David. The same man who kidnapped them in the first place drove them back to the bus station and bought them each a ticket. David doesn't know what happened to the dozens of other people in the house.
那个人告诉大卫，如果他向任何人说话——警察、记者——贩毒集团就会来找他，带走他的儿子，杀死大卫。那个绑架他们的同一个人把他们开回汽车站，并给他们每个人买了票。大卫不知道屋里的其他几十人发生了什么。
Most migrants who are kidnapped and released, the cartel gives them a key word. It's like a passcode that indicates the migrant has paid off the cartel so they aren't kidnapped again. But David isn't given one, maybe because he hasn't paid a high enough ransom.
大多数被绑架并释放的移民，贩毒集团会给他们一个关键词。就像一个通行码，表示移民已经付清了赎金，不会再次被绑架。但大卫没有拿到，也许是因为他付的赎金不够高。
When we met David in Monterrey, he didn't know what he was going to do. On day one of the kidnapping, the cartel had taken David and his son's immigration paperwork, and they didn't give it back. Without that paperwork, he doesn't even know which day he's supposed to show up in court.
当我们在蒙特雷见到大卫时，他不知道该怎么办。在绑架的第一天，贩毒集团拿走了大卫和他儿子的移民文书，没有还给他们。没有那些文书，他甚至不知道应该在那一天出庭。
But even if he could figure it out, he told us, he's too scared to return to Nuevo Laredo. Under MPP, he'd have to pass through the same port of entry to get to his hearing. What if we get kidnapped again? He asks.
但即使他能弄清楚，他告诉我们，他太害怕回到新拉雷多。在MPP政策下，他必须经过同一个入境口岸去参加听证会。如果我们再次被绑架怎么办？他问。
Last week, I got a phone call from David. The family they've been staying with in Monterrey wants him gone, and he's lost hope in the asylum process. He thinks they won't be listened to, that the hearing process is a lie. And in fact, he's right about how his case is likely to come out. Under this administration, it's virtually impossible to gain asylum based on gang violence.
上周，我接到了大卫的电话。他们一直住在蒙特雷的那家人想让他离开，而且他已经对庇护程序失去了希望。他认为他们不会被倾听，听证程序是个谎言。事实上，关于他的案子可能的结果，他是对的。在本届政府下，基于帮派暴力获得庇护几乎是不可能的。
So David's decided to take his family back to Honduras, the country they tried escaping in the first place. According to Homeland Security's own statistics, thousands of other families are making the same choice.
所以大卫决定带着家人回洪都拉斯，那个他们试图逃离的国家。根据国土安全部自己的数据，成千上万的其他家庭也在做出同样的选择。
Emily Green. She also reported on David for vice.com. A little update since we first ran this story. David returned to Honduras, and then his family scraped together enough money to send him and his son to Spain, where a cousin lives. They got to Spain just before the coronavirus hit. They do not venture outside.
艾米丽·格林。她也为vice.com报道了大卫的故事。自我们首次播出这个故事以来的一些更新。大卫回到了洪都拉斯，然后他的家人凑够了足够的钱把他和儿子送到西班牙，那里有位表亲。他们在新冠病毒爆发前夕到了西班牙。他们不敢出门。
So one last thing before we end today's program. When we were in the tent camp in Matamoros, I learned that the way that the Remain in Mexico policy was working back then, it applied to adults. But if a kid would show up at the border without an adult, the border agents would have to let them into the United States. Darwin, that 9-year-old who's the king of the camp-- you remember him, from the beginning of the show-- he and his mom told Aviva back in November that they had talked about this, about whether she should send him over alone, to fend for himself.
在结束今天节目之前还有最后一件事。当我们在马塔莫罗斯的帐篷营地时，我了解到当时“留在墨西哥”政策的运作方式，它适用于成年人。但如果一个孩子独自出现在边境，边境官员必须允许他们进入美国。达尔文，那个营地的国王，9岁的那个——你还记得他，节目开头那个——他和他的妈妈在11月告诉阿维娃，他们谈过这件事，关于她是否应该送他独自过去，让他自生自灭。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
She told him, look, as a mom, it's not that she doesn't love him. But if there's no way for them to go together, she'll send him alone. But he didn't want that.
她告诉他，看，作为母亲，并不是我不爱他。但如果他们没有办法一起走，她会送他独自去。但他不想那样。
No. Porque-- [SPANISH].
不。因为—— [西班牙语]。
No. Because of the fear that I have.
不。因为我有的恐惧。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Honestly, you won't lose me, she says.
老实说，你不会失去我，她说。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
My fear is that I'll lose my mom. The kids there don't see their moms.
我怕我会失去妈妈。在那里的孩子们见不到他们的妈妈。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I've never been separated from her, she says. And she jumps in. Our love is inseparable. That was November. But just a few weeks after that, his mom decided to send him over, because the cartels had noticed him in the camp and tried to recruit him. And they threatened him if he didn't sign up. Aviva talked to him this week about what it was like to leave his mom and walk across the bridge to America without her.
我从未和她分开过，她说。她插话说。我们的爱是分不开的。那是11月。但就在那之后几周，他的妈妈决定送他过去，因为贩毒集团在营地注意到了他，并试图招募他。如果他不加入，他们就威胁他。阿维娃这周和他谈了离开妈妈、在没有她的情况下过桥到美国是什么样的感觉。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
He was really sad.
他真的很伤心。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
It broke my soul to leave her. Once he made it to America, Darwin was put into a shelter and then sent to live with a foster family in Michigan. They treated him well, he says, like he was their own kid.
离开她让我灵魂破碎。一旦他到了美国，达尔文被安置在一个收容所，然后被送去密歇根州的一个寄养家庭居住。他说，他们对他很好，就像对待自己的孩子一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
The first day there I got a hamburger. He lived with a second foster family. And then, after three months, he finally got what his mom was hoping for when she sent him across. He's living with his aunt, has his own room, lives with a cousin who's close to his age. He told Aviva that for his 10th birthday they had a party and baked him a big tres leches cake.
在那里的第一天我吃了一个汉堡。他和第二个寄养家庭住在一起。然后，三个月后，他终于得到了他妈妈送他过去时所希望的结果。他住在阿姨家，有自己的房间，和一个年纪相仿的表亲住在一起。他告诉阿维娃，在10岁生日时，他们为他举办了一个派对，并为他烘烤了一个巨大的三奶蛋糕。
Y Darwin, [SPANISH].
达尔文，[西班牙语]。
Darwin, are you happy to have come to the United States?
达尔文，你很高兴来到美国吗？
Si.
是的。
Si?
是吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Yeah, because I'm learning English, little by little.
是的，因为我正在一点一点地学习英语。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
You wouldn't have rather stayed with your mom?
你不是更愿意和你的妈妈待在一起吗？
Mm-- [SIGHING]
嗯—— [叹气]
[SPANISH].
[西班牙语]。
Well, I really don't know what to--
嗯，我真的不知道该——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
I would have come.
我会来的。
Porque?
为什么？
Why?
Mm-- no, no, no, no, no, no. [SPANISH].
嗯——不，不，不，不，不，不。 [西班牙语]。
No, no, no. I would have stayed with my mom.
不，不，不。我会和我的妈妈待在一起。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[讲西班牙语]
Because she's all I have.
因为她是我拥有的一切。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "THESE ARE MY PEOPLE" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[播放音乐 - 约翰尼·卡什的“这些人是我的同胞”]
Well, our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman with help from Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show includes Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Additional production on this rerun by Noor Gill.
好吧，我们的节目今天由纳迪亚·雷曼制作，阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德协助。制作今天节目的团队包括埃尔娜·贝克、埃马努埃莱·贝里、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、达米安·格拉夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、杰西卡·卢森霍普、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、本·费伦、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。本次重播由努尔·吉尔额外制作。
Our managing editor for today's show is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Interpreters for today's show were Gabriela Muñoz, Catalina Maria Johnson, Daniel Sherr, and Mario Michelena. Our fixer in Matamoros was journalist Vero Cardenas. The voices of the asylum officers in the first story of the show were performed by Maggie Siff and Betty Gilpin. By the way, you can see Maggie Siff on Billions and Betty Gilpin on the Netflix show, GLOW.
我们今天节目的编辑主管是吴黛安。我们的执行编辑是大卫·克 a 斯滕鲍姆。今天的翻译是加布里埃拉·穆尼奥斯、卡塔琳娜·玛丽亚·约翰逊、丹尼尔·谢尔和马里奥·米歇莱纳。我们在马塔莫罗斯的联络人是记者维罗·卡德纳斯。节目第一部分中庇护官员的声音由玛吉·西夫和贝蒂·吉尔平表演。顺便说一下，你可以在《亿万》中看到玛吉·西夫，在Netflix的《美女摔角联盟》中看到贝蒂·吉尔平。
Special thanks today to Harrison Nesbitt and Amy Kaufman, Kimbrell Kelly, Reynaldo Leanos, Jr., Kennji Kizuka, Christopher Turpin, William Dobson, Didrik Schanche, Russell D Lewis, Clay Boggs, Maureen Meyer, Nick Miriello, and Woodson Martin.
特别感谢哈里森·内斯比特和艾米·考夫曼、金布雷尔·凯利、雷纳尔多·利亚诺斯二世、肯吉·基祖卡、克里斯托弗·特平、威廉·多布森、迪德里克·尚切、拉塞尔·D·刘易斯、克莱·博格斯、莫琳·迈耶、尼克·米里洛和伍德森·马丁。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thans, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he recently cooked dinner for some friends who hate onions and anything in the onion family.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX传递给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他最近为一些讨厌洋葱及任何洋葱类食物的朋友做了晚饭。
And they wanted to keep the leak to a minimum.
他们想把泄密减少到最低限度。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。